now to an 8 news now exclusive update on
a story we first brought you earlier
this month a woman was scammed from her
online business after someone paid her
with fake money on top of that
surveillance video shows her teen son
was injured after his foot was allegedly
run over by people associated with the
buyer when they came to pick up the
order and pay the remaining balance well
her story caught the eye of someone
thousands of miles away and they reached
out to eight news now to help Victoria
Saha joining us now with this
heartwarming update Brian Jessica
saucedo is a small business owner and
she loves making personalized apparel
and invitations she says every dollar
she makes goes towards bills so when she
was handed four hundred dollars of fake
cash it set her family back and when we
talked to her earlier this month she
wasn't looking for a hand up but simply
wanted other business owners to be aware
that this could happen but somehow our
story made it all the way to Texas and a
man named Rod Adams wanted to help
here's how you surprised her
we told Jessica saucedo we were coming
by because we wanted to check in and see
how she was doing since our story aired
emotionally I have been a mess it's been
hard because everything is just piling
up on us my husband he leaves six in the
morning and he doesn't come home until
eight o'clock in the night a few days
ago we found out that a man in Texas saw
your story and reached out to eight news
now
and sent me some money to give to you it
is four hundred dollars exact
the money that you were missing
so I'm gonna hand this over to you
this is so meaningful because as I
mentioned earlier when I text you um
this is like a blessing to my family
um we don't have it on this is a
big blessing a big big big blessing and
I am so grateful to whoever did that but
thank you so much Victoria I'm so
thankful for you thank you so so much of
course it's the least we could do I'm
glad we didn't know where this story
would go but somehow somewhere someone
in Texas saw it and they wanted to help
they were adamant to help but would you
like to speak to this person we gave Rod
Adams a call Rod this is Victoria with
Channel 8. good
um happy tier is here because I'm with
Jessica and I just gave her your
donation and she would like to thank you
personally hi Brad it's Jessica I just
want to tell you from the bottom of my
heart and from my family that we greatly
greatly appreciate the generosity that
came from you it's very meaningful to us
and I just want to thank you
well you're more than welcome Jessica
and I'm glad the Lord led me to help you
out we use everything we have and we go
straight to something thank you so so
much
these are stories that you just never
get tired of hearing and you know Ryan I
actually spoke with Rod the donor
earlier this week and he says that he's
been so fortunate in his life that he
just felt like he needed to help this
Mom no matter where she was
and boy did he help her what an impact
you see it on her face in her reaction
that kind-hearted Texan Rod stepping in
to make such a difference in the life of
that Las Vegas Victoria thank you for
bringing us that story